good morning millennials well welcome
back to the morning toast happy tuesday
i was not expecting to be delivering a
duet performance i was very much
expecting to be giving a season either
it just like came out no 100 and i'm so
happy you're here and i'm hoping you're
excited enough to sing with me yeah of
course and if we're going to sing we
must sing
snitch on the toes
snitch on the toast
snitch on the toast
snitch on the toast that's right
snitches on the toast after months and
months of trying to book her we finally
by the way by the way this was the first
time you asked me and then i said yes
well like i just knew you were so busy
like overwhelmed with like being a new
york city lifestyle influencer running a
global brand having a real job like i
just knew you were so busy yeah so that
was me being considerate that was really
kind i appreciate it but then i kept
like every time you guys posted the
schedule like in all the comments i was
being tagged and i was like [ __ ] this is
like so awkward yeah no but like you
were we were gonna get you here no
matter what yeah and we needed a little
a little injection of snitch for sure so
now's the perfect time
no time like the president there's no
time like the president and we have a
lot to discuss before we dive into the
fast five which are really good today um
but the first thing i wanted to tell
everyone is it's a big day at spritz
society we are finally launching if
you're a patreon member you already know
this but we are finally launching our
variety pack so you no longer have to
buy all four flavors separately if
you're looking to get all four there is
a variety pack with eight cans two of
grapefruit two of blood orange two of
pineapple and two of lemon and it is
available on sports society.com right
now patreon members got their code so
don't forget to use that you can also
always be using code toast
and it will be available in stores in a
little bit but right now it's on
sportssociety.com so i want to tell you
that and also i'm the star of the
campaign oh right that's why it's like
so special that you're here today you're
actually here on a press tour no
literally you went to stagecoach with
all your influencer friends and we threw
you up a little party and we had a
photographer and you guys are the face
of our campaign yeah and how did it feel
to be a model for the most premium
alcohol brand in the market i mean like
being in a bathing suit was like truly
my worst nightmare but i was
appreciative of the gene shorts that i
was allowed to wear um and then when he
asked us to like someone to get on the
float and like you know be completely i
was like oh he asked me and i was like
sir no you waited i was like immediately
so i gave it to emily who has a six-pack
and it's fine perfect you guys looked so
cute in the campaign yeah no it was
actually so fun except like we were
legitimately dead and it was so hot out
i know like we we kept stagecoach a
little bit on here um but without you
so just give me a couple words to
describe the experience i mean it was
like actually like the best time ever
yeah like there's nothing bad like it
was so premium yeah
happy for you yeah i know super happy
for you i know
looks like you had great tickets i did
thank you for that we did take a shot to
you once we got there that made me feel
better and all the girlies the
influencer girly's texting me and you
know what i really have to thank you
because in recent weeks in combination
with like having um a lot of the girlies
come on the toast but also just
you really in the last kind of three
months
turning into like one of the most
premium lifestyle influencers in new
york like you
are one of those girls now no i know
you're in the crew i know and they had a
group chat and you added me to it and
like now i'm in a group chat with all
the girlies and chat and it's like
popping off remy yeah it's popping off
and like i'm
obsessed like i don't want to write too
much in the chat but i also like don't
want to be like distant no yeah don't be
distant so like this morning like there
was like stuff going on in the chat and
like i was like doing my makeup like
giggling yeah and ben was like what's
that i'm like oh it's just um it's just
my influencers chat like don't don't
worry it's like it's literally called
the influencers and i'm obsessed with
like being a part of this group so i
just wanted to thank you for that oh my
god of course like i'm like you brought
me into so many amazing circles oh
that's so true we're just like as jill
zarin would say we run in a fabulous
circle of people we do um and the other
thing i wanted to talk to you about is
you're kind of here obviously on your
spritz modeling promo press tour but
also you are here to discuss the new
the rebranded
the
elevated the improved snatcher yes tell
me a little bit about that journey for
those who don't know
margot is my sister i mean if you're
listening and you don't know that i
don't i don't know where to begin but
margo hosts a podcast on our network
toast news network called the snatcher
and for a while it was bachelor recap
yes but you know in recent years the
bachelor
franchise and just like the show has
really declined 100
i just like didn't have the energy to
care about these people anymore right
also i'm in this like weird situation
where i'm like kind of friends with a
lot of them now and like i just it's
sticky and like i just don't want to do
it anymore and like if you hate the show
like you're going to be bringing
negative toxic 100 to your podcast and
like who wants that yeah like the only
reason why it was good is because like
there was a time where there was like a
built-in audience but like that audience
isn't even there anymore because no one
watches it right watches
so i was just like it's time to change
like either [ __ ] or get off the pot and
so i [ __ ]
love that for you
and we are we rebranded and it's now
it's gonna be more like lifestyle like
nicole's in law school i'm a corporate
girly girl also like influence or
whatever you're single
both single like just like living our
lives in new york so like you know
things come up we have a new segment
called the ick of the week and like oh i
love that right what was the ick of the
last week i didn't finish the episode
for me margo didn't want me to listen to
it because i get agita but and i did
listen to it and it was very funny but i
didn't get all did you guys do the
sausage part no but i see everyone's
like talking about it yeah yeah yeah
yeah um
what was i saying the ick of the week
was mine was oh i was just talking to
this guy on hinge and like the
conversation was like fine like we had
like two back and forth and he just goes
give me your number
oh and it was like so weird and then
also update that i was gonna say on the
snapchat but i just like didn't answer i
was like that's like just so aggressive
it's really aggressive and also because
the conversation beforehand was like
still a little weird so i was like
and then he just writes like four days
later he goes pls
please oh i'm like what does pls stand
for oh my god i'm so old i don't know
any of the new acronyms
please please that's really weird but
like i don't know maybe you should give
it to me no i'm like scared though now
that is so funny i'm so excited for the
rebrand of the snatcher jackie and i've
been begging you for like when did we go
on vacation where we had that
conversation um december we've been
making you now for like five months to
do it because you're so interesting you
lead a fabulous well i had to wait for
clayton season to be over yeah and then
like i just like wanted to like take
some time and when the show comes back
do you think you'll still recap a little
bit yes yeah yeah but it's not gonna be
like a full-fledged like we used to like
recap and also talk about like how we
felt about it now we'll just talk about
how he felt about it so like you used to
be in the podcast charts in tv and film
have you changed to society and culture
no you probably should probably should
because that's more like accurate
reflection of the podcast i didn't think
about that yeah and so the first episode
is out you released it on sunday what
has the feedback been it was your
stagecoach recap yes it was feedback has
been great and like you know people have
no problem giving critiques yeah of
course of course of course but i haven't
really gotten any everyone really likes
new the new format um they thought it
was funny and and it was long it was
like over an hour which is like very
hard it's so hard but like when you're
just like chatting with your girlie like
it actually is not that hard like we
probably will do an hour today because
we're just like sisters right exactly um
and are you gonna have guests on because
like i am free no no i am gonna have
guests on i just wanna kind of wanna get
into a rhythm first and then like i'll
get gas and you don't want to be a
podcast that like solely relies on
guests not at all because that's like
the worst yeah like i want like uh gals
on the go by because like they rarely
have guests but they do sometimes but
they like do not rely on it at all and
they're on the go
constantly and you know you could say i
want to be like the morning toast girls
because we don't really have guests
either but that's fine that's fine i
mean not as of late you don't look up to
or respect your sisters it's fine no
i don't i look at the toast as a new
show it's fine i feel like that's fair
it's totally fine oh my god you just
here's the narrative again
you're just here like to hurt me oh
you're so crazy
no i'm kidding um i'm so happy for you i
love the new artwork oh my god so good
the reviews are rave and this is what
i've been waiting for for a long time
and i feel like this is just going to be
so great for the snatchy community i
hope so and it's just i don't really
know what to do with instagram though
because like that is bachelor yeah i
mean you can still do bachelor content
you could
like kind of how the toast is like
content about the podcast yeah that's
what you're gonna have to do yeah yeah
yeah and just like memes and like fun
lifestyle like hinged stuff you know
okay fine is hinge your app of choice i
really do like locks club my only issue
with locks club and ruby if you're
watching i'm sorry um is that
you only get like six or so swipes and
then or like you you get there's a set
number of swipes and then you have to
wait six hours to keep going and that's
when you're on like a binge you can yeah
so then i go to hint you should do an
episode on like all the dating apps and
like
i'm on bumble and i actually do not
understand how to use it yeah do they
still do it like i have to message you
like yeah women's but i can't figure out
how to do that and like honestly i'm all
for women's empowerment but like when it
comes to dating like i need a guy to do
it first no i know no i know but like
it is what the times are changing so if
you need like good episode ideas like i
think that's a good one you can do like
a whole [ __ ] about like
guys you met on different apps and like
i don't know but i also see like all the
same people you do yeah why because
there's only so many people like in your
age in your area yeah in my criteria
like jewish like
right right that's funny yeah um
well i'm so looking forward to all the
snatcher has to offer us this year and
we are so blessed the tnn community that
you'll be sharing with us and we want to
thank you thank you for having me and i
also want to thank you for being here
and delivering the fast five i tried to
cater them a little bit towards you um
there's one story in specific that i
know like you are going to um
cream your pants over oh so um should we
just get a twist yeah sure okay here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
let me just get my glasses billion
dollar beauty they believe you should
have the option to purchase just the
shades and products you actually use
without sacrificing quality or
convenience and that's why the ceo and
founder of billion dollar beauty
designed the completely customizable
compact billion dollar box as a
sustainable solution to expensive
excessively packaged makeup palettes the
billion dollar box is a portable makeup
kit that uses its spill proof magnetic
lining and kickstand mirror lid to
secure a full-time professional quality
cruelty-free cosmetic
so rather than buying an entire palette
when you run low on a specific shade or
you want to try something new you just
refill the singular shade and go it's
only slightly larger than a smartphone
and the new personalized palette is
perfect for travel honestly the makeup
industry is so wasteful so this is like
a really really good call um and all
their products in the box come in
minimal recycled packaging and they're
paraben free vegan and they're leaping
bunny certified cruelty free they have
over 40 beauty pans and products to add
to your box like the number one
best-selling universal brow pencil the
magnetic brush trio
um the box came to the studio like maybe
a month ago and i've been using it every
day before the toes just like touch up
and look glamorous for you guys and it's
really such premium premium cosmetics
and i just love the idea of not having
so much crap to walk around with so
billion dollar beauty for 20 years has
been trusted in beauty and nail salons
around the world from japan to australia
you may have seen them in the clean
beauty section of target join the refill
revolution and build your own billion
dollar box at billion beauty.com and
receive 20 off your entire purchase when
you use code toast at checkout so it's
billion dollar beauty.com code toast at
checkout all right are you ready first
up we got to talk to your girl american
idol alum gabby barrett is pregnant with
her second child oh i saw that gabby
barrett and kade foener announced on
sunday that they are expecting their
second child together um
they shared the ultrasound video on his
instagram along with a sweet snap of the
couple going out to dinner to celebrate
mother's day he wrote happy mother's day
to my amazing strong and fruitful bride
such a biblical word yeah fruitful
if anyone caught me fruitful i'd be like
get the [ __ ] out of here
she is this is what she said she is cr
currently carrying another precious life
made in the image of god a son to bear
our name into the next generation our
children will rise up and call her
blessed the husband also praises her all
right we stand a biblical king
it sounds like a sermon they're really
religious i know i know i know because
they're super young she's 25. she's
sorry she's 22 he's 25. she's 22
currently and she's on her second child
like does that give you anxiety or what
oh my god wait was so how was she when
she was on american idol like 18. yeah
that's crazy i do think it's really cool
how like she's able to she's really
rising up in country no i have so many
things to say about gabby barry because
like when she was on american idol i was
like feeding for her to win i was
obsessed with her rivers deep
so good like whatever if you haven't
seen that performance just google it
it's literally life changing it's
amazing and like i remember everyone's
like saying all this [ __ ] about her like
i remember like hearing stuff about her
and i was like no like i'm here for
gabby barrett and especially now
to become a star from american idol like
that just doesn't happen no it does but
like not that level like you're you're
like famous on tick tock that was on
american idol in the new reboot
right that i have someone maddy poppy no
no who that girl katie who yes wrote an
original song and sang katie who
literally sang the most amazing
performance with katy perry they did
like an acoustic version to um
another lunch yeah
no this is the is that that's i just
said part of me yeah part of me
if you haven't seen that performance it
will change your life and you'll have a
whole new respect for katy perry's
vocals okay like she's not at the
grammys no offense no but she is famous
so sorry i just want to make my point
continue anyway no so i just think that
what she's done is so impressive also
because her music is so good so good and
that's what i was gonna say like she's
managed to reach this like really
historic level of fame post-american
idol and she's not sacrificing like her
personal life i don't love that for her
she got married she's having two kids
and it's not stopping her and like she's
kind of toxic in the sense that she's
doing it all and like nobody can but
like she's doing it no she really is and
also like kade's like in her band now
like yeah okay so that i think is part
of the reason why she's able to have so
much success is like her
husband so for those who don't know it
was also an american idol yes they
started dating and now they're married
he kind of forwent his personal success
yeah he did to be a part of her future
it's like they looked at each other and
was like which one of us is going to
have a success
and then we'll support the other and he
is like her lead guitarist i think they
write songs together it's really sweet
and i think that's how they're able to
like you know have kids go on tour
because like they're both together no
yeah it's really sweet they're really
like so cute i'm so happy for them and i
just like can't wait to see her star
rise even more no she's really like on
people are saying she's like you know
the next character well they say she's
the next kelsey ballerini who's the next
like carrie underwood like they're all
lined up to take over
um and now that you saw carrie underwood
live i have to talk about cat underwood
because i mean i've always loved her
music obviously i was never like a stan
stan like whatever
her performance
after luke holmes she was my favorite
like she knows how to put on a [ __ ]
show like she ate her legs her legs her
outfit her voice everything her voice
like just crazy also she had like four
outfit changes they were sickening like
her last one was like sick sequin jean
jacket that said like carry coach on the
back like she just gets it she gets it
and then she had axel rose come out to
saying sweetheart
down to the paradise
like just iconic and now do you really
understand like why she's the queen of
country music 100
and like she i guess i didn't realize
like how much she like impacts like
not my style but like my country style
in a sense because like when she like
came out and was an outfit like in her
pink shiny cowboy boots like my friend
looked at me and she's like wait this is
actually you no end with carrie
underwood i guess i don't realize
because she looks so young and fresh but
she's been around
forever so like so many of the songs
that she performed when i was watching
your instagram stories
i don't even realize like i knew so many
carrie underwood songs no and like oh i
don't wanna spend my life waiting
waiting
like
you don't realize how much of her music
you've been influenced by for so many
see you again
i was hysterical and then it's like the
new music is just as good yeah cry
pretty this is our kingdom like crazy
angels so good ghost story
ghost story yeah like i'm gonna be like
yeah
that song is so good so it's like she's
really so impressive from all facets so
do you think gabby barrett had like i
personally believe kelsey ballerini has
what it takes i do too to be because a
lot of people are like kelsey valerie
like she's glitz and glam she doesn't
she's not country really have you ever
heard that [ __ ] sing and play guitar
like she's extremely talented 100 i
think she has what it takes to become
carried out are you talking about heart
first
by kelsey i haven't sorry i was like
who's hartford you pronounce things
really weird like before the show you
were like we're going to talk about the
variety back i'm like what's friday pack
i don't know what that is like you
talk weird
i said heart first you said hartford i'm
like
stassi shorter's daughter
first hard first i haven't spoken about
it but i was dming
with kelsey okay um it is a glorious
masterpiece of beautiful music and
it's so good i was telling her i'm like
it sounds like a 90s country song that
would be at the end of a rom-com like
it's like this ethereal like vibe she's
like the whole album is that vibe can't
wait i'm gonna jump right in baby with
my heart first that was good that was
like
literally are you coming for my throat
yeah kind of are you coming for my chest
literally yeah it's so good i completely
agree so now
long-winded question is do you think
gabby barrett has what it takes to be
the next
next carry-on i think she does she has
she has a little ways to go but i think
she
after kelsey ballerini i don't know who
else it could be besides gabby barrett i
can't think of like another like blonde
right queen yeah and like so
the way that i think country music like
his fans looks at like the next women in
country it's like the next carry in the
next miranda lambert and they say marin
morris is the next miranda lambert and
kelsey ballerini is the next carrie
underwood that's so interesting yeah i
don't disagree i remember we hated
miranda lambert and okay so
like i love her marco i talk about this
sometimes on the toes thanks for
listening um there are two people in
this world like i'm
you can really
see that people are capable of change
when i talk this year and like five
years ago about miranda lambert and
selena gomez do you love selena gomez
now i would take a bullet oh really okay
obsessed a lot of it has to do with only
murders in the building
but then rare beauty and then just like
her recent like resurgence on tick tock
i just think like i was totally wrong
about her for so long and who else we
were wrong about was nick bile we can
never forget nick viall perfect example
yeah thank you for bringing that up
so congrats to gabby barrett i can't
believe she's 22 with two kids like
that's just me the existential crisis
like we were having on the phone last
night um
yeah that's this is i wasn't expecting
it to go into today but
i guess now it is i'm happy for her
really super happy
moving on
next up another music queen how taylor
swift feels about joe alwyn sex scenes
in the new hulu series oh so joe alban
sat down with gq for like a full like he
spread his legs like i told him
everything um talked about folklore
evermore obviously taylor
um and he's in the new conversations
with friends okay which everyone's like
quaking about was off
written after
um
i can't [ __ ] speak english sorry it's
writ it's
oh my god
it's adapted from a book
same author as normal people so like you
know she has like a cult following
and he's like the star in it and he's
gonna if you did you see normal people
no i know i need to watch it you didn't
watch it i know i don't know why it's so
good i know mezcal's so hot you're gonna
like fall oh i know everyone's obsessed
them in daisy like i know you have to
watch i know i don't know what's wrong
with me so there was like a cold
following of the show now her next book
and she's like very sexy you know so
he's like the big sexy character and
everyone's like quaking because we're
gonna get sexy and so
joe alwyn isn't worried about taylor
swift watching him get hot and heavy on
tv he said i mean she's read the book
and she loves the book she knows it um
taylor just like couldn't be a bigger
fan of the project
so you go through like a lot of
rehearsal and kind of in-depth
conversations about the intimate scenes
and kind of what story we're trying to
tell hopefully each intimate scene feels
different or there's some kind of
progression in their relationship so
apparently taylor is an erotic queen
like me because she i can see that for
taylor dress
dress but like we know taylor loves to
read and like the fact that taylor
taylor's definitely reads like colleen
hoover 100 she definitely loves like
porno just like me it happened one
summer it's probably your favorite
that's what i was gonna say taylor if
you haven't read it happen one summer
like add it to your list it is erotic
and
window shopping did you read that one no
by tessa bailey it is chef's kiss oh and
the other one um
i could really i went through like a
phase where like i couldn't read
anything except erotic like novels oh my
favorite
okay wait what's the one
same author as it happened one summer
and like she started another like series
um do you know what i'm talking about
no okay just give me a second oh my god
i got signed out of my goodreads i
[ __ ] hate this new phone i can't
just look up jackie told me jackie told
me you know how to get my safari tab
back to the top
i do yeah know how to get your safari
tab
and the new phone they're always [ __ ]
with you you know i don't know but i
don't know like if i want to search on
safari it's at the bottom
but
[ __ ] hate you
you're literally so annoying so sorry
claudia you would do the same [ __ ]
thing no i know okay i hate like when we
spend no i know okay just give me a
second it's written by
are you sure it's tessa valley yes hot
and hammered
what's the first one in that series
tools of engagement no okay these sounds
sound bizarre okay hold on it was about
a baseball player it was so cute not was
it fix her up fix her up
oh i've never heard of it it was so cute
myro like he was like a disgraced former
baseball player and she's like this nerd
and like he comes back to their hometown
and like they start this like fake
relationship it's so sickeningly cute
i'm in the middle of reminders of him oh
the new colleen hoover which i
personally honestly did not love i mean
it's not i already know it's not my
favorite yeah um but it's good it's fine
it's fine but like i guess i've just
been so tired recently that like every
time i read that fall asleep which never
happens and that's what me and jackie
were actually saying yesterday like the
rating that you end up giving a book
really is like based on like how quickly
you read it 100 like if you're like
stringing it along like i started it
last week normally i'd be on my third
book that's weird yeah yeah um but back
to taylor and joe like as much as i'm so
i mean i'm gonna watch this and mostly
because like i gotta see joe always get
down no i need to watch it through the
lines of taylor i know but um this is
just so like un taylor not that taylor
would ever like stop joe from like
progressing in his career but like she's
so private and you remember miss
americana she's like always talking
about like her body and how like if
anyone were to ever get like an intimate
photo of her like
she would feel so like she's not like a
sexy queen she doesn't dress
super risky like we don't even know like
what her cleavage looks like right like
she never shows us so i just feel like
this is like a level of intimacy into
taylor's world that we're not used to
yeah no that's true but i love that
she's not stopping him from like i was
gonna say that from achieving his goals
and like his dreams i agree also like i
feel like he could be super successful
and like she just doesn't want to get in
the way of that and i appreciate that
and i think he's well on his way like
he's very much like a serious actor so
he doesn't have like commercial appeal
yet yes but him being in like a viral
hulu show like that will change sorry no
one's seen like the mary's queen of
scots thing he was in right exactly he's
always in like royal things where i have
to watch subtitles like i'm not gonna
watch it i understand but now he's in
like a porno hulu show like i will be
watching exactly sign me up sign me up
first in line streaming um and also like
like i'm curious to see what he looks
like no also because it's like that's
what
taylor sees at night yeah
that's just
so interesting and the gq article was
really well written like he was an
article or video article i know
he's just like kind of this like british
man of mystery i feel like we know
nothing about him and the article was
very um
eye-opening i read the excerpts not the
whole article but i just but i feel like
i learned a lot about him no i would
like i'm going to read it it was and he
looked really cute he got like his whole
spread
everything's coming up joe always i
thank god it's about [ __ ] time it's
about time because like he has been
living in the shadow of his megastar
girlfriend for like a little bit too
long do you think they're engaged
currently there's like i think that
they're married yeah i think that taylor
probably won't get married legally even
though she's like oh yeah she's such a
hopeless romantic like the idea of her
not like having a fairy tale wedding i
know but she's she's also a
businesswoman
i agree so if she does get married being
engaged it will be like to be like you
know
you're not my boyfriend it'll be like
what's their name goldie hawn and kirk
douglas like everyone's favorite what's
the name of that when you're like
domestic partnership yeah yeah like
honestly marriage is just a piece of
paper 100 and that piece of paper really
[ __ ] up your business like you could
have like a marriage
like you know you get married in
you know on the beach without a real
piece of paper yeah that's what i feel
like she would do okay i think so too
she's smart cookie but goldie and what
is that guy's name everyone likes to use
that as an example like when they don't
get married they're like we're goldie
and is it kurt kurt um kirk doug no i
don't know something russell kurt
russell kurt russell i think so
um all right well we're going to keep
going but not before excuse me stop
drinking lacroix before the show like
because
i'm not okay yeah
not before i let you know that the rest
of today's show is brought to you by zip
recruiter i know you thought it wasn't
margo but it is thank you i just wanted
to clear that up for you
you guys certain people in life can just
make it so much easier for you and you
know you don't know what you would do
without them
and that's why zip recruiter is so
important because if you like growing
your business you need to hire zip
recruiters making hiring so much easier
because they do the work for you and
right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
toast zip recruiter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates with your job you can easily
review these recommended candidates and
invite them to apply
your top choices so additionally zip
recruiter has a complete suite of tools
that makes it easy to filter review and
rate your candidates four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
it's a no wonder the zip recruiter is
the number one rated hiring site based
on g2 satisfaction ratings as of january
1st 2022. so if you're a small business
you're a big business you're looking for
an executive assistant you're looking
for a sales person a marketing person
we've used zip recruiter over the years
to find amazing candidates and you can
too it's so easy it's so much better
than any other hiring set it's efficient
they let you invite people you like to
apply and it's just really efficient we
found the last time we used a recruiter
we found someone in two days
the hardest thing you have to do is
remember
the link that's really the hardest part
about using zip recruiter it's
ziprecruiter.com
toast don't get it twisted that's where
you go to try zip recruiter for free
once again that's ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire all right accounts ready for the
next story i'm more than ready so dave
chappelle's hollywood bowl set where he
was attacked
will not air on netflix that's so stupid
it's so dumb the most talked about
moment from netflix's first ever comedy
festival perhaps one of the most talked
about moments from any comedy festival
isn't coming to streaming netflix
announced a list of content being
released from its netflix as a joke
festival and dave chabel's hollywood
bowl event where the comedian was
attacked on stage last week is not
included the set's absence isn't due to
the assault however allegedly sure the
streamer made it clear before the
festival that the comedian's four sold
out hollywood bowl shows were not being
taped for a special chappelle had his
own cameras present to film the show as
comics often do when working out new
material as dave chappelle was
professionally shot footage of the
attack likely does exist and it could
eventually see the light of day in some
fashion but it's not a part of netflix's
plan i wonder if
if if it's true that has nothing to do
with the assault
like when dave releases it yeah like it
did dave chappelle just like not give
them permission to do it right like
maybe the
price wasn't right i just don't but
they're always just like throwing money
dave chappelle's way i know and i can't
imagine he was like the headliner of
this festival he did four shows the
whole thing is like this festival is
like we're gonna have this amazing
festival and we're gonna stream it like
right so you're telling me like the
biggest name on your list like your
headliner yeah i don't know if i believe
that no it's very odd i do believe that
dave filmed it himself even if he's
never gonna put it out because comedians
always are filming their own stuff just
to like work through but here who is he
hears who is getting a streaming service
a streaming
is being streamed thank you um in may
john mulaney is honoring a bunch of
comedians like robin williams dave
chappelle is honoring richard pryor and
chelsea handlers honoring
joan rivers which should be fun and john
stewart is honoring george carlin then
june 6 bill burr is getting one uh june
7th through 12th david letterman and his
like six episode thing i
have hate in my heart for david
letterman i'm sorry um june 9th is an
lgbtq plus celebration june 10th is a
tribute to bob saget june 11th is amy
schumer june 13th is pete davidson
presents the best friends so it's
multi-common comic special hosted by p
davidson that's where that clip that
recently came out is from you see he was
addressing kanye joking that pete had
aids no
they gave like a like a three-minute
netflix release like him finally talking
about kanye yeah um and it went viral
and honestly like i didn't think it was
that funny
he was just like connie is a genius so i
was thinking do i have aids oh god yeah
um
june 14th jane fonda and lily tomlin
ladies night live because they're from
that show
june 16th snoop dogg has an original
comedy june 23rd uh highlights
throughout from the 11 day
festival
and then the big special that doesn't
have a date yet is gabrielle iglesias
playing a sold out show at dodger
stadium
wow that's so cool i don't even know who
that is i do he's like really really
famous okay so he's gonna say like
telling him [ __ ] nuts and i thought
my msg theater was a big chance no
that's crazy um i'm like
loving this i think netflix is the go-to
place for comedy i'm just like where's
the dave chappelle content no yeah that
actually is a sick lineup was a little
too spaced out for i know i did just
watch um a new special on netflix
remember chris destefano from guy code
yes and he's all over tick tock now with
this hey babe podcast tupperware
no you don't know tupperware no
margaret wait you
you're a tic-tacker and you don't know
tubberware
that podcast video clip where he was
like i gave my daughter the tubberware
and the other guy's like wait what did
you just say it's like my daughter he's
like no the other thing tubberware
yeah say the first syllable tub
wrong
why do you see that clip no from the
hate babe podcast oh my god it's so good
no i haven't seen it we're on two
completely different sides of tick tock
yeah obviously i'm like on comedy tick
tock because i'm [ __ ] hilarious right
um whatever so he's like really big
podcaster comedy and his special was so
funny it was 35 minutes which is like
really short so short but i do i did
hear somewhere that he has like an extra
15 minutes he's releasing on his youtube
channel we stan a content king yeah um
and i highly recommend it was like
pandemic comedy and it was very funny
okay
but i think that netflix throwing their
own comedy festival is really smart very
smart i think this is a great idea
upset i wasn't included but i love 100
love every minute of it yeah happy for
them yeah who's your favorite comedian
oh like currently alive
alive joan oh sorry
of all time joan rivers alive dave
chappelle okay who's yours
oh i don't know i don't have an answer
like i wasn't expecting you to throw
back at me which this is like a two-way
conversation i understand um i feel like
you're not like a comment i really like
sebastian madison i think he's hilarious
so do i and the fact that you didn't say
me is why we're literally not friends i
can't
um so
dave chappelle
whatever like
like annoying yeah um also i want to see
it so no same like i want to know what
joke what triggered this person yeah
um the next story is some tv news that's
really interesting so hbo max nabs a
non-please a production drama based on
jumoi's book with a script to siri's
order oh my god so it's really
interesting listen because at first i
was like what the [ __ ] but the sh okay
so hbo max and wptv had secured
preemptively the rights to the book um
to develop it into a drama series
so did you write a book already so dumas
is a pseudonym obviously an instagram
account yada yada
the upcoming book a non-please written
by joomla with the new york times
bestselling author jessica goodman will
be published
november 8th by harpercollins okay in
the book here's the synopsis of the book
that's what i was gonna ask qriket lopez
is an assistant to one of the most
notorious celebrity stylists she revamps
her old style instagram account and
turns it into a celebrity gossip blog on
a drunken whim and she never thinks
it'll become anything it's just a way to
blow off steam after a terrible day at
work
where her nightmare boss screams at her
and blames her for everything but when
the account grows overnight and even
wilder she starts getting gossip from
fans juicy gossip she has to face facts
her instagram is now famous she is now
famous though no one knows she's behind
the account it's newfound success is
affecting her real life her boss wonders
why she's disappearing on the job her
friends are increasingly irritated by
her dedication to the account and she
has celebrities investors and
journalists approaching her with
bright-eyed interests plus there's a
steamy new love interest who she meets
through her online persona except she
has no idea if she can truly trust his
motives but as the account grows and
becomes more and more famous she has to
wonder is it the fame the insider access
the escape from real life really worth
losing everything else so that is the
scenario sounds amazing that's the
synopsis for the book and then hbo was
turning that book into a series wow so i
feel like this is actually a really good
um no that it's the plot i wasn't
expecting the plot to be that good like
an actual like
fiction yeah fictional story i mean it's
fiction but like based on truth
i can never remember nonfiction is um no
here's how i remember it
like you know
[ __ ] like
i always know that fiction is not real
wait
fiction is not real okay because like
fiction means true yeah because like a
fictional character is like fake right
that's how i know it okay for some
reason it's just one thing that will not
stick my only thought on this thing is
like
it's a really good plot but do you think
it can be well you wrote the book so
oh sorry i forgot about my alter ego
yeah i'm so excited about mine you're
just like you're like i was like he's
just like went white i was like what are
you talking about but what i was gonna
say was like this does sound like a good
plot but like do you think it's a good
enough plot to be adapted well into a
book and a movie or like is it movie or
serious serious sorry like is the series
gonna be better is the book gonna be
better oh um i feel like this like it
sounds like it's more meant to be um
like a series that's what i was thinking
so when i when i read this as the plot
for the series i'm like oh that actually
sounds like kind of good but then when i
thought about it as a book i'm like um i
don't know are there gonna be like fake
celebrities in the book like you know
what i mean right right not to make up
fake people i mean one of them has got
to be good yeah no hopefully and i think
it'll i'm putting my money on the series
okay yeah i think so too also hbo max is
a good job production value's high
exactly and you know what
kudos to me
um for really turning that page into
like something more you know yeah oh my
god it could have easily not been
monetized right no and like that
person's like spending all their time at
dumas but also like working you know
in a regular job that person has a
regular job no i'm saying that's what
could have happened but they really
turned it into like something legit
agreed
so i think this is interesting and i
will be watching the show i don't know
if i'll be reading the book to be honest
that's fair i don't know if i will be
either are you ready for the fifth and
finals is this the one that's making me
cream my pants heard we got that was
gotta be barry okay okay i would like
wasn't you didn't know you didn't feel
the cream
[Music]
no um are you ready for the fifth and
final story i'm ready for the final
story but did you know that it's brought
you
by feels i didn't know you did yeah wait
how did you know that spoiler alert cbd
isn't about what you feel it's about
what you don't feel and that's stress
anxiety pain and feels is a way
to feel better feels is a premium cbd
that will keep your head clear and feel
your best it's hassle hassle-free
delivery directly to your door cbd
naturally helps reduce stress anxiety
pain and sleeplessness there's no
hangover or addiction so personally why
i've started looking into cbd years ago
is for sleep i'm just like not a good
sleeper i'm not on a good sleep schedule
um and i love taking the feels products
i think it's really helpful with like
stress before bed and anxiety before bed
like israel like putting them in your
brain days in your sleep so you're
having sleep inside like
sleep and cbd is a great way to combat
that you place a few drops of fields
under your tongue and you feel the
difference within minutes the thing to
remember about cbd is that finding your
right dose is important and everyone's
dose is important so or the sword
or
if you need a dose of chill on the go
you can pop one of their feels new cbd
infused mints for a clear-headed feeling
and bonus fresh breath feels offers a
free cbd hotline to help guide your
personal experience so that you find
your perfect dose the feels customer
service team is dedicated to making sure
you get the best use of your cbd the
idea of them having a hotline is so
helpful because it can be kind of
intimidating like getting into cbd for
the first time you can also join the
fields monthly membership to make your
self-care easy you'll save money on
every order and you can pause or cancel
anytime start feeling better with feels
become a member today by going to
feels.com toast and you'll get 50 off
your first order with free shipping 50
is a lot that's fbals.com
toast to become a member and get 50 off
automatically
off your first order with free shipping
at feels.com
toast all right counts
ready for the fifth final story it's a
little art news oh a little auction news
is this can i guess
i mean yeah there's literally only one
piece marilyn monroe yeah so andy warhol
the painting that he made of marilyn
monroe the iconic one that everyone
knows has broken records yesterday at
christie's and sold for 195
million dollars so the famous silk
screen andy warhol made of marilyn
monroe sold for 195 mil at a christie's
charity auction i mean that money goes
to charity
no way
i was about to say does that go to andy
warhol or marilyn monroe
it's like such a good question and
they're both dead so like like the
estate right no
excellent question but it says charity
auction monday night setting a record
for the most expensive piece of american
art ever sold the iconic warhol painting
shattered the previously record
the previous record set by the late
brooklyn artist jean-michel basquiat um
his 1982 skull painting sold for 110
million dollars at sotheby's in 2016.
that really surpassed the record uh-huh
and warhol had held the second record
prior to basquiat um his 1963 work
silver car crash sold for 105 million so
the auction house estimated warhol's
1964 painting would be at 200 million
dollars before the event the winning
bidder was identified as art dealer
larry gagosian oh like like the museum
yeah so he bought it for his museum or
for his house it's gotta be further
look all proceeds from the lot 36a will
go to the thomas and doris amman
foundation zurich which puts the
painting up for auction the foundation
aims to help children with health care
and educational programs wow it's for
charity that's insane but who owned it
before that like gave it up for charity
unclear also
like obviously i know like
these people have so much money that
like it's different but could you
imagine spending 195 million dollars on
something that hangs on your wall no no
i literally couldn't like it's crazy it
couldn't be me because like i do
appreciate art to a point like i do
think art is beautiful and art should be
expensive and there's different values
for different art for sure but like
that's just i'll never be like a queen
who like goes to someone's house and
like looks at the art and like cries you
know
100
okay but here's the back story of the
painting and why it's so valuable
originally it was one of the five silk
screens painted in 1964. the 40 by 40
inch prints were stored in a stack at
warhol's new york studio the factory
dorothy podber
who was a performance artist stopped by
and asked if she could shoot them he
said yes oh
this is a picture
it's not a painting it's a silk screen
i don't know what that means so the
performance artist asked if she could
shoot them the five silk screens he
painted he said yes presuming she meant
with a camera
oh sorry no wrong then the performance
artist pulled out a revolver and shot
all of them except for the turquoise
print in the forehead
oh my god wait this is so interesting
not understanding a word so andy warhol
had five like of his famous paintings in
his warehouse his performance artist was
like can i come by and shoot them he
said yes because she he thought he she
met with a camera she's a performance
artist so she came in and shot him up
oh i thought they meant what they used
to call like movie things
no
and she shot all of them except for the
marilyn monroe one
oh so she schemed him she schemed him
andy had the four paintings restored and
they became known as the shot maryland's
oh and this was the only one that wasn't
shot all five paintings have been sold
for various amounts of money over the
years first in 1967 the blue background
painting sold for five thousand dollars
the orange background sold for 17
million in 1998 and then it went to the
hedge fund manager ken griffin for a
rumor 200 million dollars
that is insane okay that is insane
that's so interesting that is
interesting we're just like our girlies
here tonight truly oh my god we're just
opening up our minds i feel like i
definitely got half those facts wrong
but like it's very confusing yeah like
watch out it's not gonna be like a
revolver no totally and like it really
doesn't go to charity no it's gotta
that's so crazy that i went to charity
like shook no i mean now i'm like yes
200 million should have been 250. no
obviously but even still just in general
like spending that amount of money on a
piece of art is so crazy well it's like
the most amount of money you've ever
spent on anything oh um
like not where it's like you're putting
something on your card and people are
paying you back like yeah no no it
doesn't count if you're just doing it to
get the point um probably like your
apartment right like when you do like
first months last month security
oh um taxes yeah that doesn't count okay
because like you have no choice yeah um
i guess probably first months last month
or like i think when i
maybe purchased
um
my cartier ring
really i don't know
cool what about you
uh actually i know what the most amount
of money you've ever spent on
what your dog walker
oh stop but that's over the course of
years that's not fair no the most amount
of money i've ever spent um on something
is probably a purse yeah
same no regrets
no none whatsoever none whatsoever
counselor it has been a delight a joy
and honor seriously to spend this much
time with you you are so funny and
everything of the sort and i love you
and i think everyone should listen to
your podcast the snatcher 2.0 revamped
you're going to love it it's not even
about the voucher anymore available tell
everyone where they can listen available
on
apple podcast
sorry it's been a while app podcast um
spotify stitcher anywhere that you can
find podcasts anywhere is where you can
find me and follow the counselor on
instagram at margaret m-a-r-g-o-s-h-r-y
i love you so much i love you so much
thank you guys for having me have a
great day at work
thanks guys don't forget
to head over to spritsociety.com get
your variety packs two cans of each
flavor that's eight cans total you don't
have to buy the flavors separately
anymore but you can if you want to stock
up on one particular flavor spritz
society.com patreon members don't forget
to use
your code i love you guys thank you so
much for listening to the morning shows
on monday morning should we deliver the
pasta oh sorry we'd have one thing to
say
just really quick scheduling update the
next two shows are ben and jackie and
they've decided to switch days for both
of their schedules so tomorrow is jackie
hump day with jackie dear toasters with
jackie thursday is ben so it's like the
same thing just like two days switch so
i just wanted and i feel like posting
the schedule on instagram again for like
one minor change i get it thank you so
much for listening to the morning shows
of the millennium morning show where we
deliver the thousands of stories that
you need to drive every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
they're
butterfly juices everybody has boxes all
the places
oh my god
that
looks crazy
[Music]
have an amazing day you guys we'll see
you tomorrow for hump day
bye
you